we are hearing emotional stories from
some of the record number of Americans
who file for unemployment because of the
pandemic our national correspondent
Jericka Duncan has been talking to
people who are out of work
Jericka good morning how they coping
good morning to you Anthony they're
doing the best that they can you know we
spoke to three people two of them said
they were laid off another person said
they were forced to lay off most of its
employees now while thousands of people
in this country have tested positive for
coronavirus millions are feeling its
effect on the workforce I'm very scared
42 year-old Michelle Jarrell of Chicago
is normally focused on fitness but these
days this wife and mother of two is
worried about her family's finances the
studio where she works as a fitness
instructor shut down last week
her husband's pay has been cut too
what's the biggest bill that your
family's facing my mortgage am I gonna
be able to you know stay in this house
knowing you know if I have credit card
bills car payments all those things add
on Monday she filed for unemployment for
the first time and took you know over an
hour to get my information in the system
it's a reality millions of Americans are
now facing 40 year old now Asha Johnson
worked as a security guard at
Philadelphia International Airport she
also filed for unemployment and is now
trying to help her co-workers with that
process and closure is something that
Matt Bell says he's trying to get his
employees in 2017 he opened a car club
in restaurant called the shop Club in
Seattle Bell was set to expand to Dallas
this summer and double his staff but
because of coronavirus concerns he laid
off nearly 40 employees
but what's the worst thing that could
happen and there's no way we could have
been dissipated how things have changed
lately fitness instructor Michelle
Jarrell says she worries about what her
industry looks like when this pandemic
is over will people feel comfortable
working out in small places and crowds
if you will she's so worried that she
even said she's considering going back
to her old job as a pharmaceutical sales
rep but Fitness is her passion so very
concerned but most importantly about how
she's going to pay how her family is
going to pay those big bills
it's a question that everybody wants to
know the answer to Jericka no
unfortunately nobody really knows thank
you very much